dernières actus retrouver regarder la
petite annonce de toufik c'est kelly et
moss et toufik
j'aime la cité des bois fleuri
maintenant voilà je suis dégoûté il ya
un chanteur tu as vu il est là
tranquille dans le terreau terre il n'a
pas la nationalisation
et puis t'as vu moi je veux qu'il est
parce que je le kiffe douves elle est
fonctionnaire a donné lui parce que
sinon on va vous hommes de bata séméga
ckoi gims c'est exactement
oui parce que maître gims voilà il était
que nikos aliagas en balade avec sur
europe 1 il a fait une révélation
étonnante regarde vous avez eu vos
papiers français
je suis toujours pas français ni cros
j'avais fait une première demande figure
toi qui marie été refusée j'ai pas eu
j'ai pas compris pourquoi je ne sais pas
je me suis dit peut être que parce qu'un
jour j'avais fait un plateau télé où
j'ai dit que 8 c'est bon je vais avoir
mes papiers
donc c'est logique c'est je crois que ça
les avec s'est emballé je suis emballé
donc du coup ils m'ont dit bah écoute
maintenant tu te refuse nationalité
aujourd'hui j'ai devant des mandats
somme était princesse je vais arriver en
france dans les deux ans et demi ils
m'ont refusé la nationalité
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'est-ce que je
peux faire - alors maître gims est né à
kinshasa au congo et il n'a toujours pas
la nationalité française en 2016 elle
avait d'ailleurs annoncé sur le plateau
du jt de france 2 et ça avance au pas
des jo parce que vous êtes son frère ça
avance ou pas j'en ai aucune idée
ouais mais tu t'en fous totalement géré
cet emprunt
non mais je nord mais je sais que je
sais qu'il est ils sont il y en a
beaucoup de gens sur le dossier donc
d'accord oui mais toi tu la nationalité
française
ouais moi je suis là il a 26 ans 26 ans
exact mais je sais tout sur toi
gentleman 2.0 c'est son album va se
retrouver dans un instant les chéris